[Musik]
das haben wir hier eine zwischenform
ausgebracht dieses zwischenverdienst dem
erosionsschutz und der fixierung von
nährstoffen
wir haben die dann gewalt im dezember
haben sie den umgelegt damit vor einem
forst ereignis der frost auch in den
boden reingehen kann so wie wir es jetzt
haben
hättet ihr bestand noch 50 höhe jetzt
können wäre der frost nicht auf den
boden gekommen der boden werden noch
weich
das war heute das nicht bearbeiten
könnten und dadurch haben wir nur ganz
kleine zeitfenster die sind oft von
morgens früher von 34 uhr es geht dann
wenn die sonne rauskommt so wie eben das
geht jetzt noch zwei drei stunden
und da müssen wir aufhören als dann der
boden wieder reich ist bei den circa
sechs wochen für zuckerrüben sehen je
nach witterung wenn die föten
abgetrocknet sind an der das nochmal
eingeebnet mit babette kombination der
boden wird ein kündigt gemacht und
solche kleinen pflanzen rückstände die
verrotten als kleine stücke vielleicht
so groß wie das sind sie noch da aber da
gehen sie problemlos durch die
sämaschine durch es gibt keine
verstopfung und wir hoffen dann auf eine
gute aussage guten feld aufgaben
[Musik]
da haben wir so nichts system können wir
auf zeichen dass in die spuren
ich habe jetzt eine spur eine gerade die
spar betriebsmittel ein weil wir keine
überlappungen haben oder wenig werbung
haben spare zeit und ist vor allen
dingen auch notare entlastungen ich kann
wenn ich habe ein knopf drückt und in
die automaten in den automatikmodus
gegangen bin kann ich die hände vom
lenkrad nehmen und kann die ganze länge
alleine das gerät steuern lassen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auch schön hier haben wir
jetzt praktisch einen weg gefahren
da haben wir jetzt zwischen drin
genau die arbeit die ich habe
ausgefüllt wenn ich das alleine gelenkt
hätte hätte ich jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich nur einen meter oder drei
meter und auch manchmal ein bisschen uhr
betreten das würde mich eine zusätzliche
überfahrt in dieser linie kosten
wir haben wir daran
produktivitätssteigerungen durch genau
erfahren können als er das viele
antworten
[Musik]